over the past 12 months carvana stock is
up
750. meaning that if you invested
$11,000 at the beginning of 2023 you'd
now have $88,500
hearing this you'd probably be inclined
to think that carvana is killing it but
if we zoom out a bit more you'll see a
completely different picture zooming out
to 5 years you'll see that carvana stock
has actually fallen off a cliff from
their peak in late 2021 carbana stock
literally fell 99 9% by the end of 2022
from $380 to
$3.63 and even with their massive value
over the past 12 months carvana stock is
still down nearly 90% from their Peak
given all the market volatility High
interest rates and high inflation it
would be easy to just ride off this
decline as a stock that was hit hard by
the macro environment but there's a lot
more to the story from registration and
title issues to stolen cars and
thousands of complaints during the worst
of it carvana's annual losses ballooned
to as much as $1.58 billion as such
carvana's decline very much has to do
with poor fundamentals as much as it
does with a poor macroeconomic
environment but it wasn't always like
this not too long ago carvana was the
startup superstar that had
revolutionized the used car market they
had made it easier than ever to sell and
buy cars all from the comfort of your
phone without having to deal with a
single car salesman that's why at their
Peak carvana was worth nearly $70
billion for perspective that's nearly as
much as mercedesbenz and the only
Automotive companies that really
outshine that number is Toyota and Tesla
the good news however is that it's not
all lost for carvana in fact carvana has
been staging one of the biggest
comebacks we've ever seen they just
posted their first real quarterly profit
of $782 million and it seems that
they're nearly 10x talk recovery is just
the beginning but what about all of
these serious concerns regarding stolen
cars and invalid titles has that been
resolved well let's find out by taking a
closer look at the controversial rise
fall and Rise Again of
[Music]
carvana if you think that carvana has
had a controversial past just wait till
you hear the story about their Founders
because it's far more controversial
taking a look back the story of carvana
takes us back to a convicted felon named
Ernest Garcia II Garcia II came from a
pretty well-off family in New Mexico his
father not only owned a liquor store but
he was the mayor of Gallup New Mexico so
safe to say that Garcia II grew up with
some pretty powerful friends and in
classic villain fashion Garcia II
wouldn't waste any time in leveraging
these connections to Rich himself which
brings us into his first business real
estate development there's obviously a
lot of money to be made with real estate
but Garcia II would often find himself
entangled with Shady deals in October of
1990 for example Garcia II would plead
guilty to fraudulently obtaining a $30
million line of credit while
simultaneously helping a local bank hide
land ownership from Regulators this
would earn him 3 years of Probation and
his firm filing for bankruptcy having
burnt his reputation within the real
estate World Garcia would make the jump
to an adjacent industry car sales in
1991 he would purchase a bankrupt to
rent a car franchise called an ugly
duckling for $1 million he didn't
exactly know how to turn around the
renting model so he would just turned
the company into a used car dealership
that targeted subprime car buyers to be
honest Garcia wasn't really in the
business of selling cars but rather
handing out loans to delinquent
borrowers in fact as much as 45% of
their car loan loans are delinquent at
any given time and they actually have
370 full-time employees to collect these
overdue payments selling cars to naive
people that couldn't afford them and
then ruthlessly collecting turned out to
be a pretty profitable business model by
the turn of the century The Ugly
Duckling was a public company with
annual revenue of $600 million at this
point Garcia would decide to Rebrand the
company in order to move further away
from his checkered past leading to the
new name DriveTime Automotive you might
have heard of it drive time would go on
to earn billions of dollars every single
year which brings us into the next
generation of Garcias Ernest Garcia III
Garcia III would follow the classic path
of a rich kid's son he would attend a
prestigious University which in his case
was Stanford before coming back to join
the family business in 2007 often times
these kids are the ones that run the
family business into the ground but that
wasn't the case with Garcia III he was
determined to take the family business
to a whole another Stratosphere he had
had grown up seeing the rise of internet
and doom companies like Amazon and eBay
he knew that people weren't quite ready
to make massive purchases like cars
fully online just yet but he speculated
that it was just a matter of time and if
anybody had the resources influence and
power to pull it off it was him so in
2012 with the full backing of DriveTime
its executive team and his father Garcia
the third would launch
caravana
with all that context it's really no
surpris why carvana went on to be a
massive success carvana was no ordinary
startup created by a couple of college
students carvana was a strategic and
calculated extension to an already
massive family Fortune Drive time or
basically Garcia II provided carvana or
basically a son with the cars he needed
the financing he needed the technology
he needed needed and the expertise he
needed now technically Garcia II isn't
one of carvana's directors or officers
but don't let that fool you this was a
strategic move to keep carvana separate
from Garcia II's past but behind the
scenes the Garcia are not only closed
but they literally live next door to
each other not to mention Garcia II is
still the company's largest shareholder
with the stake of roughly
25% also the Father's son Duo owned
super voting shares in carvana which
gives them full control over the entire
company but I think that's enough about
the Garcia family because there's plenty
of controversy to cover regarding
carvana itself it's not that carvana is
a direct scam if you order a car you
will indeed get your car and if you sell
a car you will indeed get your money but
there's a lot more to buying and selling
cars than just transacting cash and
authorizing loans and this is where
carvana really fall short over the years
they've built up a habit of cutting
corners and turning a blind eye to
everything that doesn't directly earn
the money such as quality according to
carvana's former employees they're not
inspecting Vehicles they're taking in
cars with frame damage and not
inspecting the frame damage they're
selling cars with unreported accidents
and cars with accidents that haven't
shown up on the Carfax yet if you're
outside of the 7-Day money back
guarantee you're screwed since these
allegations came out carvana has gone
ahead and put out a bunch of articles
about how much they care about quality
but you you can take that for what you
will another concerning piece of
evidence against carvana is their
management of vehicle titles carvana's
lead lawyer Paul Bro is facing a
whopping 57 criminal charges in the
state of Illinois this includes 27
counts of failure to transfer vehicle
titles and 50 counts of improper use of
titling and registration Illinois would
even go as far as Banning carvana from
the entire State on two separate
occasions and that's just the tip of the
iceberg zooming out carvana was selling
cars with Hit or Miss quality had a
bunch of title and registration issues
their lead lawyer was facing dozens of
criminal charges they were facing
Statewide banss they were also facing a
class action lawsuit they were selling
stolen cars and they were getting
thousands of complaints through the
Better Business Bureau if all of that
wasn't bad enough carvana's cars were
usually sold with super high markups in
q1 of 2023 for example carvana boasted a
per car profit margin of an astounding
61% why do people agree to pay these
ridiculous markups you ask well they're
usually just uninformed customers who
are sold the vision of convenience and
not having to deal with car salesmen
when in reality it would probably be in
their best interest to haggle with a car
salesman than buy through Carana with
all of that being said this is precisely
the type of company that you would want
to avoid with a 10 ft pull yet carvana
would go on to have their run of their
lives thanks to the
pandemic
the pandemic was basically the best
thing that could have ever happened for
carvana with everyone stuck at home and
often scared to go outside buying a car
completely online was a more desirable
option than ever combine this with 0%
interest rates and massive stimulus
checks and it wasn't long before people
were casually buying cars from carbana
as if it were a $50 Gadget you ordered
on a whim from Amazon
on top of this you had the chip shortage
which made it nearly impossible to buy a
new car in a timely manner and before
you knew it used car prices would
Skyrocket in fact for quite a bit of
2022 you could have sold your existing
car for a higher price than you bought
it for as such Revenue at carvana would
explode from $3.9 billion at the end of
2019 to nearly $15 billion by mid 2022
similarly carvana stock would rocket
1,00% from the pandemic DC bottom
transforming them from a multi-billion
dollar company to a several Deca billion
dollar company but eventually the music
would stop playing for carvana in mid
2022 as Jerome po started jacking up
rates given that carvana's bread and
butter was selling used cars with
massive price hikes to uninformed
customers who couldn't really afford
them increasing interest rates really
took a toll on carvana combined this
with the chip shortage finally coming to
an end and used car prices calling down
substantially and carvana would take a
big hit on revenue and an even bigger
hit on profits which brings us into
carvana's single biggest issue burning
money despite selling used cars at far
larger markups than virtually anyone
else in the industry the reality was
that caravana was never really
profitable it turns out that buying
shipping and selling cars across the
world was extremely expensive not to
mention the hundreds of millions they
were spending on Advertising per quarter
in fact this trend only got worse during
the pandemic as their revenue ballooned
so did their losses which peaked at just
under $1.6 billion investors didn't
really mind these losses when Revenue
was growing multiple fold and Car Sales
were through the roof but when the
narrative changed so did the sentiment
around the stock if declining revenue
and massive losses weren't bad enough
carvana's Corner cutting over the past
decade would finally start coming to
light almost in unison and just as all
of that was happening internally at
carvana the entire stock market would
take a nose dive due to recessionary
fears High inflation and high interest
rates strong companies like Facebook and
Netflix themselves would crash
75% so it's not surprising that carvana
someone with shy fundamentals was hit
even harder though it is still crazy to
think that this led to a full 99% crash
since then it's not really clear how
much of this thing caravana has really
cleaned up to be honest it doesn't seem
like they really care to do much more
than what regulators and states are
forcing them to do in terms of providing
a better service however they have got
their act together on the financial side
of things just recently posting their
first real profit in history of $782
million and this alone has been enough
for a lot of investors to buy back in
but that doesn't change that if you're
shopping on carvana you should still be
more than a bit careful as this is the
type of company that you're dealing with
unlike carvana a marketplace with a much
more wholesome story is Craigslist check
out this video to learn more but until
then I'm hry I'll see you guys on the
next
one